hello and welcome to the Daily climate
show coming up as the UN Secretary
General calls for Net Zero a decade
earlier is Britain on track for its
existing targets
African countries agree to consider debt
relief in exchange for more ambitious
climate action and on International
Forest day we hear about the role they
can play in reducing climate anxiety in
the Young
[Music]
thank you
hello and welcome to the Daily climate
show the show where we highlight the
change changes taking place to our world
and investigate some of the solutions to
the crisis now yesterday saw the release
of the latest un report on the state of
the climate with International
scientists saying it presented a final
warning to humanity to avoid irrevocable
damage U.N Secretary General Antonio
Gutierrez warns that richer nations may
need to accelerate their path to Net
Zero reaching it as close to 20 40 as
possible and with a report last week
warning that Britain is off track to
meet its later deadline of 2050. How
likely is that to happen well earlier I
spoke with Helena Bennett from the think
tank green Alliance she told me there
are things we can definitely do to help
what we can do is try and accelerate
emissions reductions now so that in 2040
we're still we're not emitting as much
as we are today so we're not we're not
basically staying at the same level as
admissions reductions today and then
cutting them all off in 2050 we need to
start seeing a downwards trajectory
today and you're totally right our
researchers showed that even for what we
call the fifth carbon budget period
which is the year's 2028 to 2032
um in the UK we aren't on track to to
meet the target within those years so
um what policies then do do we need to
implement not just talk about and put in
place but actually Implement to achieve
that Target by 2040 I know of course the
UK is doing very well on renewable
energy but what else
so critically I think first of all in
the UK we need to um heed warnings of
the International Energy agency and not
um start any new fossil fuel projects so
things like the Cumbria coal mine and
the rosebank oil fields these undermine
our targets to get to Net Zero and
that's just in the UK let alone
everywhere else
um there are a variety of policies that
we've identified currently sitting in
consultation phase or in the ambition
phase so that what that means is the
government has said we want to do X or
we're going to consult on X but we don't
have it legislated yet and that means we
aren't able to make any progress on
emissions reduction so a couple of big
examples that we've identified and so
cars represent the biggest single source
of emissions in the UK the government
has started on track to delivering what
we know is a zero emission Vehicles
mandate I.E sales Targets on car
manufacturers to sell electric vehicles
not yet legislated and it's been delayed
so we need to see that coming through
and but we also need to see things like
more public transport and walking and
cycling for people to have as options we
need to use less energy so bringing
forward money and policies to insulate
people's homes and retrofit people's
homes install heat pumps and solar
panels those kinds of things and really
importantly there are opportunities
across all sectors of the economy in the
UK to make savings on emissions through
things like changing behavior and more
efficient use of resources and greater
circularity it's great to Greater
circularity and I think really
critically the biggest thing in my mind
is making sure that we're introducing
policies and strategies that aren't just
going to be ditched by the next
government these policies span decades
climate change is something that we need
to think about in the really long term
we need to be thinking about stuff we're
doing today that's going to have an
impact in years to come so we can't keep
introducing these piece more policies
that are ditched immediately by whoever
Administration we have in power at the
time when you cross-party buy-in in the
UK on climate and we need to make sure
that what we're delivering is going to
be fit for purpose in the future as well
well Britain has so far cut emissions by
around half since 1990 and the
government for its part says it is a
world leader in working towards net zero
but to admit the world does need to work
faster towards more ambitious reductions
ahead of cop 28. okay let's take a look
now at some of the day's other stories
for you and African nations have agreed
to consider a debt for climate swap deal
to reduce their debt in exchange for
commitments on climate action it was
among several green initiatives
discussed at a un meeting of Finance
ministers in Ethiopia that supporters
say would boost funds to adapt to
climate harms protect nature and finance
local communities or many African
nations are on the front line of costly
climate change events
the EU is planning on marking an
exception to its law Banning new cars
with internal combustion engines
according to leaked documents seen by
Reuters law was agreed last year
requiring all new cars sold in the EU
from 2035 to B zero emissions but
Germany declared a last-minute
opposition requesting an exemption for
so-called e-fuels generated from
renewable sources rather than fossil
fuels the move was criticized by France
who are themselves trying to push
through an exemption for nuclear energy
Joe Biden is set to announce two new
national monuments that will protect
more than half a million acres of land
the U.S president will name Avi Kwame in
Nevada and Carson range in Texas as the
nation's newest monuments ensuring their
protection from Mining and development
it does though come after President
Biden approved more Drilling in Alaska
for the controversial Willow project
now today is international Forest day a
un initiative designed to highlight the
importance of our forests around the
world or here in Britain our forest
cover is among the lowest in Europe
depriving many of us with the positive
mental health benefits of spending time
in Woodlands and that's something the
Woodland trust is working to improve and
the chief executive of the Woodland
trust Aaron moorcroft who joins us from
Derbyshire is with me now now Darren it
has been a bleak assessment this week as
far as the ipcc is concerned you've got
some research out today about climate
anxiety among young people in particular
what more can you tell us about that
that's right we've commissioned a yugov
poll and that's shown quite worryingly
this the scale at which young people are
feeling that climate anxiety so one in
three young people in the UK feel they
are scared or pessimistic about climate
change and really feel worried about the
the effect that climate change is going
to have
um and we know as you've said on this
very special day and we would say every
day of the year is a International Day
of forests
um nine out of ten people recognize the
real benefits of getting out into Green
Space into our Woodlands uh for those
physical and mental health benefits
sister tell us more about that I mean
how does spending time in in Woodlands
help us
I think the range of benefits that you
get it can lower your blood pressure it
can it can help to create a an
atmosphere for you where it can calm you
down if you have that anxiety and I also
think you know one of the key things
that the Woodland trust does is
establish new woodlands so we've
established over 8 million with young
people of the 55 million trees that
we've established through our through
our history so far and we want to do
even more and the really important thing
that that does is it gives people a
connection and it gives people hope
because they're taking positive action
you know when a youngster is putting a
tree in the ground what I would say
they're doing is they're creating a
connection with nature a connection with
the battle against climate change but
also they're going to create something
that's going to last for Generations so
their connection might be a lifetime the
habitat that they create will be
generations to come yeah that's a
wonderful way of putting it isn't it
well of course there has also been a lot
of very worrying stories about tree
felling recent Lee
um are we actually making improvements
on Woodland cover in in the UK
I think it's definitely a work in
progress and it could do better if I was
marking the report card I think as a as
a society as Government particularly we
have to drive those numbers up in terms
of the area of Woodland cover that we
have as has been said we've only got 13
if you compare that to Mainland Europe
they're closer to sort of 42 to 43 and
it just shows that when you have a
technology if I can call it that you
know a natural solution for both climate
change and for biodiversity uh the
biodiversity crisis as well as helping
people with their mental health and
physical health we need to get more of
it out into the uh out into the
countryside as well as out into the
streets that in where we where we live
chief executive of the Woodland trust
good to have you with us on the climate
show thank you
now before we go just a reminder that
you can hear the latest episode of The
Sky News climate cast by scanning the QR
code on your screen right now you can
subscribe for free wherever you get your
podcasts
well thanks for watching that's all from
us for today bye-bye
foreign
[Music]